FEMALE NEWS REPORTER >> The main question
that Davos leaders are asking themselves is
how can global growth be restored in 2009.
MALE 1 >> Hmmm. How can global growth be restored
in 2009? [scratches chin]
MALE 2 >> The global crisis our generation
is facing is very profound and it is very,
very dangerous, indeed, because it is going
to touch every aspect of our lives.
MALE 3 >> According to people's view, or at
least to YouTube's poll, anyways, people don't
feel optimistic about the economy. If people
perceive the economy of being bad, then the
economy is going to go bad. The investors
are going to be tying their pockets, no more
investments. People are going to be tying
their pockets, no more spending. You know,
companies are not going to be hiring if they're
not making any money or getting any investments.
When will this economy be restored? When people
have faith again.
FEMALE >> This seems to be a recurring theme
throughout the people I talk to and I believe
a seed of worriness and fear of the year ahead
has been planted. And, in my opinion, it will
take more than a year, and a few changes on
the interest rate market to remove this lack
of confidence that has been ingrained.
MALE 4 >> We should understand that the economy
is cyclic, meaning that this, there are periods
of growing and periods of decreasing.
MALE 5 >> With regards to the economy I don't
have any one solution. I don't think anybody
has one solution-ah-um-there will always be
cause for debate-um-with regards to any solution.
MALE 6 >> Whether-maybe this year-if this
year, will be the year that we actually bottom
out in which people like you, government officials,
industry leaders can work with everyday Joe's
like me.
MALE 7 >> If global growth could be restored
in 2009, that would be a miracle. I believe
modifying the date to 2010 would be more adequate.
MALE 8 >> [Background music] What we need
[holds up a hammer] are the proper tools.
Using the improper tools can lead this recession
into a depression. Improper tools such as
increase in taxes, protectionist trade barriers
and contraction of the money supply.